we're here with the amazing claire foy
and paul bettany the new stars of a very
british scandal although there's nothing
new star about you you are both
extremely established
okay well um in wanting to get to know
both of you a little bit better
sometimes i like some sort of like you
know different questions not about work
not about family just about you will you
guys play a round of final five with me
100 yeah
all right
claire
it's midnight you're at the fridge you
can't control yourself what's your late
night snack
oh
i'm really low rents are basically
anything that was in there
anything old and with mold on it i'd
probably eat
i'm so sorry i'm gross no uh no anything
anything yeah do you have a favorite
food
sweet things if there was like a pie or
cake
or a baked item that wouldn't normally
be in the fridge but it's in the fridge
apparently so i would eat that baked
item in the fridge well i motor boated
some food at midnight the other day
i was like how about just some toast and
jam
um okay um
paul whose posters were covering your
wall other than jennifer connelly you
know on your walls as a
kid oh
duran duran oh my god
he's gonna try and say something cool
like the jam or something but the truth
is it was simon the bomb i mean we had
the same bedroom we got the same posters
yes
yeah
hey we have something in common i love
this okay claire what is your worst
habit
um
all of the ones everyone else has the
boring like the boring ones like looking
up people on the internet you shouldn't
do
oh i like that one fun google searches
okay um paul which member of the royal
family would you want to go to brunch
with if you could henry viii
i like that i wasn't going there in my
mind i went current i really went
history very smart um okay to both of
you um what's your rainy day activity if
it's raining outside what are you doing
yeah beer
yeah i love meal
definitely beer yeah ugh
yeah but the beer chicken
like being under a duvet
watching things on telly watching
patrick swayze and ghost oh yeah
maybe with some beer i don't know
um his name is sam in that movie
i love that movie so much i just i just
watched it with my daughters they love
that movie i'm with you a duvet a nice
cocktail
a little like something else hey a whole
day you can go buy under that duvet
i bet it can
[Laughter]
and if you want to see all of these
yummy chemistries and details and rich
characters and history and all of it
then please watch a very british scandal
because it is available to stream on
prime video this april 22nd
paul and claire i have been looking so
forward to speaking with you and meeting
two people that i'm such a psycho fan of
thank you claire boy and paul bethany
[Applause]
[Music]